[Music]
dave
we've been friends for a long time long
time now
i've got a series of very probing
questions here
okay and here's what's gonna happen i'll
read a question and you'll read a
question
we will both answer the way that we
think the other person
will answer okay brilliant our markers
here are our two drinks you have the
margarita yes
i have the martini with the blue cheese
olives and there's real alcohol in there
and it's early in the morning it is just
the time just to let the audience
in it's 11 o'clock in the morning right
yeah but you know what
it's five o'clock somewhere okay let's
see what happens here we go
first question ben shapiro will
eventually try
marijuana i will make it
oh wait this is what you're gonna say
too yes yeah yeah
you are right i don't think he will
eventually try the peruvian parsley
he will try it and that's because i'm
eventually just going to put it
in some sort of kosher meal yeah yeah so
he will accidentally try it
i don't think he will voluntarily no
smoke weed but i think at some
conservative event that we do i will
bring the hummus
and i will have put in a little bit of
marijuana yeah
and stone ben shapiro will speak at
normal person
then you can still slow down yeah but
not working
yeah yeah that's yes i like that there's
also the question of
he could get a contact tie i have no
idea what i think he's moving
on that show yeah yeah he's beyond
contact he's beyond yeah you're right
his defenses yeah so we were totally
right about each other we we write about
each other
so we should probably probably drink if
i if
if i know the rules which i don't yeah
and in honor of
shapiro and all right
kamala harris will become president
before 2024.
so it's not before 2022 it's not before
the midterms
not before the midterms but before the
end of this joe biden term
is over
yeah that old bastard isn't making it
come on what are we doing here however
yeah i'm gonna have to correct you
i don't think you think he's gonna make
it i think he's got whatever is keeping
him alive right now whether it is drugs
or marionette strings
he i i think he is too prideful
to not serve out one full term i don't
think he's gonna make it even
five seconds longer than that right but
i think he's going to make it the full
term do you think that right at the end
they take him out back like old yeller
like that's what she's that's what she's
going to do joe joe there's something
out there have you been to the backyard
at the white house yeah
think of the flowers you know the
rabbits you're right
okay well so wow i'm shocked you got a
drink i'm shock knowledge
but you know uh solidarity with you i
suppose i'll drink too
to old joe may he last
thinking of the rabbits george the
difference there by the way is that i
just think he will completely break down
the next three years you think he can
they can drug
i mean think what a state we're in
america that your honest assessment
is that they can drug him or use strings
he what about just a weekend at bernie's
kind of thing well they just have pelosi
and commodities that's that's basically
what happened at that
fake state of the union that happened a
while i mean that
he barely made it through that yeah but
the guy you know he
he's got piss and vinegar running
through his veins all right that guy i
think he wants to make it yeah
all right all right donald trump's
presidency
was a net good for the republican party
that's a tough one i'm gonna
save it yes i actually want to put it
even
we agreed we agreed despite the shambles
that the party is in
despite the split despite the revolution
that's coming and the gulags that we're
going to
we both still think it was in that good
i don't say despite i say because
because of it bring it on baby right
you're always a little ahead yes
if it's going to happen bring it on yes
absolutely well since we agreed
we should probably drink cheers you know
to the breakfast of champions
ooh that's salty that's salty and that's
okay
okay back to the middle dave next prompt
is to you
cigars are just pretentious cigarettes
hmm wow well well
your your answer is yeah your answer i
think you're and i think your answer too
i could be
i could be wrong you know what i i think
the answer is no
for me on that i've hung out with you
people yeah
that's still what i call you guys you
people but i've had you and
uh clavin and some of the other people
at my house
prager cigar guy you guys all smoke your
cigars
maybe i smoke something else at the same
time who knows but are you doing it out
of pretentiousness out of
some sort of higher than that or are you
doing it because you enjoy it it's not
pretentious
if it's not pretend and the other thing
is you know
i love cigars you just come up with that
i write on the spot that's always yeah
i i i've smoked cigarettes a handful of
times but
i don't really smoke cigarettes i don't
really actually yeah i'm remembering the
last time we had dinner yeah right
before i fled
and yes i remember when you lied to me
about it when i lied to you and then i
didn't look back and turn into a pill of
salt
yeah it was me smoking a stogie yup
you not smoking a stogie clavin smoking
a stogie prager smoking a stogie adam
corolla
cigarettes ripping cigs yeah and that
what does that prove so
you know well adam much more man to the
people i would say much
but however i don't think i don't think
it's a pretentious thing i think it's
just a matter of taste
it's just a matter of taste you like
that taste that's right that smell
and you know what this is and other
people don't like it but you like
pushing it on them
disputan domest nothing pretentious
about that latin phrase at all there's
no accounting for taste there's no
accounting for your table
all right next question yeah we should
drink that right yes yes
we don't have cigars here
[Music]
that's good all right a lot of vitamins
and things yes
drink
what that's the prompt just drink just
drink so well you got to figure out what
the other person is going to say to that
you understand so that the prompt is
driving it's getting very so will you
agree with that or will you not agree
with that
yeah let's say yeah
all right wow we got that right we got
that one right okay all right this
we're going deep we're going deep that
was the easiest one to answer all right
caitlyn jenner is the most likely
candidate to win in the recall
of gavin newsom so we have to be pers
are we saying
including newsome i see you are a true
political pundit yeah i
because the average person may not know
it doesn't mean that newsom is just
disappearing because the recall he gets
to run
again it's just triggering a new
election so it's a wonderful technical
point you're making
but let's let's just say among the among
the non well let's just say among the
non-nuisance the non-new some cash
right that's true because they're going
to be allowed caitlyn number one out of
the non-new service
okay so i'll answer for what you think
and you answer i think
so yeah it's it's got to be right yeah
right so there's no question kate well
it creates this problem do i say he do i
say she i i leave that to your personal
choice to my personal pronoun choices
however whether he or she caitlyn has
hired a
very expensive team of very prominent
republican consultants
raising a lot of money has been taking
this very seriously
i was hoping there might be a different
candidate
for governor of california a sort of
likable person
with a high profile and broadly
conservative views more conservative by
the day you might say
you talk about randy quaid because he's
considering randy quaid
that's the one yeah that's the one i see
what you're doing there
but i just was wondering there's still
time before the election
nils as i told candace the idea that at
3 a.m my phone would ring
and they'd say governor rubin there's
been an earthquake in san bernardino
yeah
like what do you want me to do about it
i was at the clubs all night right like
it's just like what do you want me to do
what do you want me to do but that
really is the problem with politics
anyone who's sane and decent
and wants to live a good life why would
you ever of course want to do it you
have to be basically
you have to be crazy but you could say
you know you you like gavin newsom
obviously is american psycho he is
passionate yeah no he really you know
what you you could pick up and you say i
am the earthquake
i am the storm baby yeah yeah i'm going
to revolution
i just don't want to take a call like
like no matt what could they possibly
what do you want me to do yeah you'd
have to go like take a photo op or
something
over you know the earth that's open
that's true but did you hear that randy
quaid is considering running for real
i did see this so imagine if it's now
1989
right 1990 and they said to you in 30
years
not only will donald trump have been
president and will already be out
but in 30 years bruce jenner as a woman
and randy quaid the cousin from the
christmas
vacation we'll be running for governor
of california you'd
to take over after a couple of other
people from
arnold schwarzenegger what a world man
what a world yep that's true
i hope i'm hoping after a few more
drinks we
i can return to this question for you
but you're right in the meantime it's
jenner versus quaid yes
all right masks will be mandated
permanently on airplanes now again we
got to be a little careful here mandated
all of the time
mandated maybe just for flu season but
some kind of mask mandate
okay
totally i have to say those in that
we've answered a lot of these
the same you're become quite astute in
your political yeah
you know i i've just learned from them
and i'll drink to that i'll drink that
um yeah that one's honestly pretty
depressing but
you know i think you and i are pretty
eye to eye on this which is that the
masks the lockdowns none of this has
anything to do with covet anymore
it has nothing to do with keeping people
safe it is a bunch of like
psychopath authoritarians who don't
understand anything about science
yeah trying to control our lives like it
has nothing to do with anything beyond
that it's the secular kefia yeah
yeah yeah in the release they've got the
head scott and that this is the version
of that
for secular libs yeah i have to say it's
nice being here in nashville where
nobody's wearing the mask oh no
we actually you know how we greet people
here we lick the nearest doorknob
we do we do just for our freedom i was
wondering what you were doing out there
all right let's see what we got here
oh this is good this is good the trial
of derek shovin was a fair
trial okay we have to be very technical
about that the trial
the trial of derek jones trial fair
trial
and this is what the other person would
say yeah
oh don't move make a move yet i don't
want you to tip me off here but i want
to think this through what would
michael knowles say
wow we agreed again so what's your
thought process on this
you know when the mob goes into a
restaurant in new york and they say hey
it's a real nice
restaurant you got here sure would be a
shame if something happened to it
why why do you have a legitimate fear of
the mob because they're intimidating and
they're they're making threats to you
but also because they've carried out
these acts of violence in the past and
gotten away with it
that is exactly what blm did that is
exactly what the
elected politicians like waters and
kamala harris
did right waters calls for violence
kamala harris bails out the rioters
and they did the civil suit before the
trial so they already gave the family 27
million bucks
right this yeah we already knew water's
at the time said if they don't get the
murder conviction
burned down the country yeah and we were
told oh the jury no don't worry it's
okay they didn't hear about it but even
the judge who said he said i'm not gonna
declare a mistrial yeah
but maxine waters just gave you a great
appeal so he's admitting he's like i
should declare a mistrial but i'm just
not
obviously it was not fair yeah i don't
even have much to add to that like that
sort of pressure and i was thinking
about it this way like if
if you were a juror on that yeah and you
had any
fear a legitimate fear even two percent
that you might be leaked
you know once once this thing's over
that your address your name you might be
doxx-like and especially now in an
internet world where you can't keep
it's like it would be within your
complete rational self-interest of
course
to go for the guilty verdict and that's
how twisted justice has become imagine
the courage required because it's not
even just you yeah
it's yours it's your family it's your
loved ones yeah absolutely yeah well we
did it
cheers you're drinking my drink mm-hmm
all right all right
in the spirit of freedom from covet you
know i feel that's
that tastes a little coveted well it
does yeah that's that is the vaccine
actually yeah
that was the best that was it right
there all right climb up there's michael
oh
sorry hold on real nice okay you wanna i
actually did it
i think i saw the word custodian maybe
okay close yes
criminal justice reform is needed in
america
now this is a very broad that's broad
that's yeah okay all right but
i'm gonna i'm gonna take it at its
broadest oh i see what you're doing once
again
it's broadest okay all right i'll touch
this one so at the broadest i know you
yeah i know you're gonna do no question
yeah like i need more death penalty we
do we need more
we have an under incarceration problem
in this country too many lawyers we have
we have first of all too many lawyers
and we have blm and antifa
yeah torched the country last year
and then at the sa that was one side of
them the other side of their mouths they
complained about over incarceration
right while none of them got arrested
none of them harris actually funded some
of them getting out of jail the funny
part about that you know this from l.a
we're still like pretty much where the
daily wire offices were
it's still all boarded up and it looks
like you're kidding me yeah
no but the best part of the board the
boards are that they all say
you know peace love tolerance whatever
blm
love everybody but it's it really you
mentioned the mafia before it's a mafia
game they're they're boarding up their
businesses saying
we're writing this stuff because we know
if we don't write this stuff you're
going to burn down
our business you know it's the worst
kind of mafia tactic yes because it's
too
the mafia tactic that you like is when
you walk into the restaurant and they're
like you know
i'm gonna pay up yeah that there's at
least a subtlety to it or at least you
know you're gonna get a free meal but
this is like
here full-on burn it down yeah in in
brentwood and so one of the nicest
neighborhoods in in l.a
i saw these boards up this was during
the height of it in july and august
and they i kid you united said
they had receipts printed on there of
the donations they had made to act blue
and blm i think how psychotic that is
there were some that said minority-owned
business yeah
like the lamb's blood like go go kill
whitey but don't please
by the way these weren't a lot of them
were not minority-owned businesses right
but because they said please please go
burn the other guy don't don't take me
we need i'm good i bow forever we took
an interesting
twist on that one they it was very uh
i like your nose i would put these
people in jail yeah
that's that's the justice reform i like
all right
critical race theory should be federally
banned from all public schools and
universities i think we can both just
drink on this one yeah let's
uh really yes yeah yeah i think we got
that one easy enough
yeah it's just poison you know some
people don't get it because they say oh
what's the big deal just ex you know
they'll have this class and critical
race theory and but then this one won't
be
there is a thought that stops thought
yeah that is the only thought there
ought to be stuff critical race theory
actually says not only you know
you're horrible because of your race or
you're great because of your race it
also
says there's no such thing as objective
truth yeah it also says like
hard work is white supremacist you know
it yeah
being on time is white supremacist like
it's here to destroy everything
like so i don't think it's a real jump
to say that
it's a thought cancer is what i would
say it's here
to destroy the ability to talk about
other ideas so
the idea that you would teach that at a
college well that might explain why all
the colleges are crumbling
right right but i think we can both
agree that asians should be banned from
harvard oh obviously that goes for that
same yeah
we need more spots for you know for us
white people
for that for yeah that's what i mean by
us you know that
do i count do i don't know if i count
i'm a little lonely no no no since you
left l.a you're a little paler
i have gotten paid that is true i know
we've got to check in with ebram candy
to see how much privilege i have in my
swarthy skin yes
roe v wade this is actually a pretty
good one for dave reuben
roe v wade should be overturned i've
spent my life trying to avoid this
question yes
now you know that now that's saying okay
that question is actually leaves open a
few different interpretive possibilities
but i mean you know my answer but right
so okay so your answer obviously is this
yes what do you think my answer is that
roe v was that the court case
that took this issue away from the
states that's certainly the dominant
reading of it
should be overturned i'm gonna out you
i think right now i don't know if you've
talked about this publicly
you haven't told me any of this
privately
i think you believe that roe v wade
should be overturned even if you don't
agree with all pro-life laws or i think
on the court case you would agree
michael as you know i made a begrudging
pro-choice
12-week argument in doper in this book
new york times
best-selling don't burn this book great
book by the way great book
um that being said and i think
maybe i've discussed this once on some
random podcast because someone flat out
asked me
the defense of the idea that it should
be a federal law
doesn't really make any sense to me and
of course you should kick it back to the
states and the states should decide
and really if if liberals could stand on
any principle that would make sense
well then if the idea is okay well now
these 12 let's say southernish states
are going to ban abortion if you really
want abortion access well then you can
still do non-profits to get people
to cross state lines i know you wouldn't
be thrilled with that and i don't
i don't love the idea i'm not sitting
here like i love abortion but you're
just talking about i'm just talking
about like court be doing and what
and what freedom is and federalism and
everything else so you were quite astute
on that one
cheers to that you were you were quite
interesting all right
well because there's a difference
between your own personal beliefs and
personal morality and what the legal
system people and what the constitution
sets up yeah oh fabulous this is great
good one whoever put that question
that is a good that is a good one i
don't you pay these people out of your
pocket right right right right right
right right you ever put that question
in
yeah and by the way am i ever going to
be paid yeah
conversations and not wielding political
power
is what's going to save america because
that's a good one too
they're good they're good conversations
well okay hold on
so i think you know i can move on this
one very yeah yeah yeah
but but what does dave think
dave five or six years ago
versus dave now i don't they might be
different answers
dave five or six years ago i think all
about the conversations
you know but to the exclusion of
wielding political power
dave of locals fame dave
of political activism
i'm saying no you're an interesting chap
you are correct i don't think
conversations can do it alone
but i would say that it's not purely
political power and you kind of hit that
there i believe we just have to build
stuff yeah and the stuff that they're
building will crumble that's why
the idea that the government is going to
save youtube or twitter it's like let it
fail
right let it fail because they bring in
programmers that are
based on diversity as opposed to skill
while people like me build things like
locals
so i think it's more about building than
wielding political power per se
but in the strict sense of the question
you still have to wield some power
that's by the way why
i never called myself a pure libertarian
right and that's a there's that
constant business it's good yeah yeah
this is good well now
somebody they're going to call us
fascists because of that answer so uh
you know
chinchin as uh to faucism
to fascism yeah um
okay oh this is grown man this is such
a real point
alex jones is more accurate than cnn
so that's good that's good alex
yeah alex jones is more accurate than
cnn
yeah no doubt there's no doubt that alex
jones are gay they're trans actually
he was he was cautious about the frogs
he was what was the deal with the frog
so he thought if you lick the frog
what was the deal there was no licking
that's something
else there is a toad you can lick that
you'll trip you know yes
that's going to be our next game yeah so
the thing about the frogs because i we
all made fun of the genderless frogs
that
you there was a study done by yale and
the epa in connecticut of these
waters that had chemicals in them yeah
the frogs were were being
disproportionately turned not
gay but hermaphroditic so they were
developing both sex organs
so alex jones was actually the most
responsible journalist in america
he brought he sort of brought it back to
the more modest claim of they're turning
the freaking frogs gay yeah but really
he should have said
they're turning the freaking frog's
trans right right right but even he knew
he could only touch it so much um i
would say my the reason my answer is yes
is that first off everything cnn is says
is basically a lie yes
virtually everything they say all the
time is a lie
you can drink to that and i would also
say that jones
and this is really true i've never
watched if i if you took all the clips
i've ever watched of him
maybe maybe it's five minutes but i've
seen like the screaming stuff
but he sort of has been directionally
right let's say when it comes to is
there a giant sort of globalist
operation that's
sort of taking over the world that we're
now we're seeing through covet and
lockdowns and everything else it's like
that's so he he did but he was directly
right about something very big
he did a bit once i thought it was one
of those crazy things he ever said
he said a lot of things are pretty kooky
yeah but he comes and he says
they're they're the globalist the
globalist triacoms are making they're
making human monkey hybrids so they can
do their experiments and
extend their lives and i was just like
okay okay here we go
yeah the human monkey huh let me just go
to santa there come a human monkey oh my
gosh he's right
no they're actually doing that and
admitting that yeah we've got human
monkey hybrids yes
that's like that was a headline like
three weeks ago oh great yeah so
you gotta gotta hand it to it right guy
has gotten a few things right all right
which is more than you can say about cnn
to our impending cancellation
all right
some type of universal health care
should be provided
for all american citizens some another
yes
yes interesting in the in the lingua
wait first off we're not yes we're not
in the center position
some some type
okay i i can answer this i think
wow knowles yeah
well you first because i think that's
the bigger shock here yeah you did it
right you would oh no of course there
should be there always there always has
been right
that's that's the answer like am i
saying that we should have like cuban
style
you know totally i've driven by havana
hospital okay people don't
everyone can go in there but they don't
have any medicine or doctors so it's
like hotel california it's like hotel
rooms
and you can never leave uh but of course
we should have something
you know if you go to an emergency room
but you don't have money they should
take care of you as
as we do in america i knew you were
going to say it and that's why i said
yes that
that that's what even put aside
obamacare for a second yeah it's what
we've had forever which is that if
there is something really wrong with you
because of the hippocratic oath they are
not going to turn you away
this was like such the lie in 2006 2007
when that was a really hot issue
people are dying on the streets and i
said i walk around a lot of streets i
don't see that happening
well you also left l.a there's people
just dropping between homelessness and
cove
yeah they're just they can't breathe
yeah all right you make a good all right
fair
all right to uh being our brother's
keeper
to giant government healthcare
all right today oh wow this is actually
a tough one
today our second amendment rights are
under greater threat
than our first amendment rights another
good one
so what does dave think about this
ah what do you think about this i'm
gonna say you're saying dave says no
i think second i'm actually
i'm actually gonna say no as well you're
right
you want me to go first on this one yeah
so the reason i think
the answer is no is that the people that
have guns are not going to give up those
guns very easily
that's the beauty of the gun it took me
a while to get there but that is the
beauty of the gun
the first amendment stuff we know people
are giving it up all the time
not necessarily because it's the
government right now but between big
tech and people silencing themselves
like
the true spirit of the first amendment
has been completely trampled
um that being said they obviously are
coming for guns
but i think there's a more functional
like guns or a literal thing that people
will not
give away i love the buy back too which
is like it's not a buy back if i didn't
buy it from you
that's everything and if you're making
me do it yeah yeah buy
that's called robbery actually yeah
exactly hey hey grandma i'm here for the
mandatory buyback of your vcr yeah
exactly
right so that that would be my position
yes that is
a good position the the gun
the second amendment protects the second
amendment yeah that's
that's part of the beauty of the second
amendment but
between the government outright saying
you can't donate it's not just free
speech it's also
freedom of religion it's also freedom of
assembly so the government says
yeah blm can assemble and steal puma
shoes but
conservatives who want to protest that
you can't assemble you can't go to
church
you can't speak and then you've got the
blob the corporate blob which is
working in cahoots with the government
it's a little blurry but they're the
ones who are really silenced
you're on big tech yeah drink to that
while we still can
all right while two freedom-loving
people
and to guns take away speak freely and
drink
so now you're up
i bought cryptocurrency so
this would be i'd be answering whether
you did yes yeah okay
um i'm gonna say
you're a conservative you know you like
the fdic
yes you like the functioning banking
system beyond that yes because i'm
skeptical
you know of the of the system but you
are right i'm a conservative
what the hell is a bitcoin i don't know
what that oh here we go listen dad i
don't have time for this right come on
okay
you should have you with your instas and
your snappies and your huh
all right so i am right that you did not
yeah you are
you said that i did now i'm going to get
you on a technicality here my friend
i have never bought crypto you've been
given it
i've been given crypto and let's just
say i'm doing quite well
um yeah yeah i have i have a bunch of
bitcoin and bitcoin is worth something
and i did not buy any of it it was early
on i
bet you know when i started hearing
about it i posted my little bitcoin
address
somewhere and people started donating
and it kept coming and coming in coming
in so i've got a nice little bitcoin
nest egg you know there was a time i was
playing
with one of the producers i was playing
uh pool yeah and i was just hustling to
the pool yeah and he said all right
he owed me whatever 50 or 100 bucks and
he said okay i don't have cash but i'll
give you some bitcoin
i said uh whatever man he sent it to me
but i'd
i never did it i don't even know how to
do it so i'm probably a millionaire and
it's
well you have an app you got what do you
got no i don't know i have
email and twitter is that are those the
apps that i don't know
all right so the ant so well as well we
should drink to my financials
yeah yeah in celebration and in regret
it's very exciting if i move to
nashville i'm going to basically buy the
town
okay
climate change is an existential threat
to the human race
man done yeah it's not it's
not it's not and even if it was we'll
get off this rock we'll figure something
else yeah
we'll figure it out man just stop
whining about it it's
just so boring i saw a deep impact a
couple people survived
you know what happened to bruce willis
at the end of armageddon i don't
remember but i think he lived
or at least affleck lived right yeah
yeah and armageddon by the way is a
christmas movie i know that that's like
a big debate
no no no you're talking about die hard
oh you just got armageddon
and dice i don't used a christian movie
it's armageddon
yeah i don't know i guess it's
christian-ish but they don't i don't
know if they
you know but no yeah yes that was your
bruce willis is an actor who's been in
several movies
i got him confused yeah yeah yeah uh
europe europe
religious revival specifically
christianity
is the only way to bring the country
back together
okay i actually want to be this is this
yeah this is this is interesting and
there's some technical stuff here
to bring the country back together
yeah yeah actually so we're a great
political thinker
it's incredible literally it's amazing
85 to 90
of the day yeah so yes because how do
you bring a country together
you bring a country together on language
we don't all speak the same language
which we're we're not even allowed to
say that
you're not even allowed to say that it
should be the language here's a really
edgy one you can bring a country
together on race
right there are plenty of countries that
are racial countries that's not going to
happen here obviously we're all
different sorts of races
well let's let's you know if ibrahim
candy and the rest of them
you know you're right yeah yeah then we
certainly won't bring a country together
uh you can bring a country together on
a shared i guess you'd call it civ civic
religion you know the
the generation for the founders
obviously they're
pulling the statues down that's kind of
crumbling right it can work for a
certain period of time i would say that
yeah yeah
but if you want to bring together well
especially if you think it's all true
then you know you want to be in
accordance with the truth but also if
you want to bring together a country
where
neither jew nor greek nor slave nor free
but all are one in christ
jesus and you have a country of humility
and charity and love of one another
coming from
the the very religion that forms your
civilization that's
that's probably a good bet that's
probably a good bet so i would say the
answer
is basically i like your drinking to
your own answer i like that you were
like
i really enjoyed what i said there and
i'm going to drink you know i wish i had
a smoke yeah
the body is a temple yeah and the temple
needs incense of course um
i would say the answer the answer is yes
to that because i think
the secular stuff can work for a while
especially in good
times and then it's the second we get
into weird times such as what we're in
right now
once secularism has run rampant where
you can't say boys are different than
girls and
all the rest of it that the only thing
that can unify at that point
is something true that is before
us something that my parents believe
that their parents believe that their
parents believe that their parents
believed
and we can whittle away whether
specifically that should be
christianity or judaism or judeo
christian what all of that stuff is sort
of
second obviously um you know what's uh
tom cruise that whole thing yeah
scientology
you know but but in essence if you don't
have that
and i think that that's what's happened
with the left there is nothing that is
true anymore
and that's not that doesn't have nothing
to do with the fact that they are
completely a religious it's an odd
position for me to argue from as you
know but i've
but it's a true world the world is what
it is
you know what are you gonna do
oh no i'm gonna get kicked in youtube
for this one
oh no was the election stolen okay
that's how we could we could both get
kicked off right now like so
in 2020 joe biden won more legal votes
than any president in american history
due to youtube rules make your guess
but do not verbally confirm if the other
person guessed correctly
give only a non-verbal confirmation so
that it's a good thing i bring my lawyer
with you
this is good he's waving his hands so
the prompt is
wait repeat it one more time i want to
get it technically totally right in
2020.
joe biden won more legal votes than any
president in american history
you know but what was the caveat related
to youtube do not so we make the guess
okay we think the other person thinks
but we cannot
verbally confirm whether or not that
guess was right
okay this this is how it all ends just
doesn't just
i don't even
next question
but i'll drink to that i'll drink a lot
i've actually been drinking a lot drink
it's just a drink
it's just a drink there you go
this was a great last youtube video i
enjoyed being on youtube
it was a wonderful time that's fine all
things must pass
i have been vaccinated for covid19 we
can probably tell this by the amount of
cell services
i have been vaccinated ah you know
like i guess actually not totally sure
no of course okay i just didn't know if
like what do you think i want i want the
third arm or
the tail coming out i know i just didn't
know because the real caveat
yes they're gonna make us do it to
travel
yes and so i've avoided it thus i've
assiduously avoided it
and you know those vaccine passports
don't seem all that
difficult to produce but they're really
pushing it i mean they are really saying
you can't leave the country some people
say you shouldn't leave the state
yeah yeah um i have not got it i see no
reason to get it yeah
in many ways the vax people are the
anti-vaxxers because they seem to think
that they can get the vaccine that still
everyone else has to get the vaccination
triple mask and still don't go out and
whatever biden said about maybe on
the fourth of july it's like these
people are these people are completely
bananas
i personally don't think that a
relatively
young healthy person should get a
vaccine that was rushed out this is just
my personal belief
that was rushed out when you know that
if you get sick
you have a 99.9
chance of recovering completely fine
just in the last two weeks my sister and
her two kids got it six years old
and two years old they were all sick for
about three days my brother-in-law who
lives in the same house as my sister
did not get it and they were sick for
three days and they were all okay should
we have destroyed the world because of
this
destroy the world destroy especially
when you're talking about the kids
shooting up rates of anxiety
stress depression yeah i can't believe i
invited a science denier
this is very it's like i'm talking about
so for the immune heresy to heresy
and to killing all the germs you know
[Music]
i'm pretty sure tequila would do it i
don't know about vodka oh yeah i don't
know jin thank you yeah
the star wars prequels are better than
the new star wars trilogy
the new one meaning this new the the
last three with the grize of skywalker
walker's a girl now or whatever that one
yes
that one with ray and okay the other
girl and
i might have tipped my hand on my view
um so this is the prequels
the prequels are better that was the
best
prequels are better um the answer
absolutely
well the answer absolutely is yes yes
let me allow me as a professional on
this one
the prequels are excellent and they are
getting better
like fine wine they tell an incredible
story about the accumulation of power
and how political leaders use a crisis
to accumulate that power and that how
once you have that power you take out
the other side that almost has nothing
to do with you know luke
and obi-wan and yoda and everybody else
but just that that
giant everlasting story in another tells
plus that jar jar binks
the jar you know incredible this is so
everyone always goes to jar jar is the
the worst part no whatever georgia is
fine it the the one that got me about
the prequels is that
the mitochondrions they took the first i
know they took i know they made it they
made it science it's like science
and yeah i know i get that but it's your
they're still better they're
they're better they're also they're true
there's a truth yes
yeah where the new ones it's just like
it was just a mess
you know i could go on my own i could go
on my
80-year rant that ryan johnson who did
the middle one he hates star wars yes
they actually brought in a guy that
hates that's right yeah and then jj just
had to try to clean it up at the end
no i agree peter cushing did a great job
i felt in the new ones but yeah
okay you think i didn't get that
reference i got the reference that was
that's the real esoteric
yeah yeah in 2021
2021 a degree from yale is basically
worthless
yeah but i'm gonna i'm gonna disagree on
my point
it's i would say you're very likely not
going to leave there with an education
uh you're very likely not going to leave
there loving your country or knowing
much about your country
you're probably going to leave confused
about like what sex you even are
but you can probably still work for
goldman sachs
you're gonna get a job at a think tank
got it yeah yeah i completely agree with
that
and and yeah the schools have let's put
it this way
you know i started a tech company in the
midst of all this if someone came to me
with a
harvard resume or a yell resume i would
be like why would i want that person
yeah i want a kid basically who learned
how to do stuff and do it right
and everything no totally all right okay
here we go
i would bake a gay wedding cake
okay this is well i think you know i i
don't know how your baking skills are
but i suspect i could get your answer
okay as i answer for you i'll think
about my answer
so the answer is complicated it depends
on the type of cake
interesting if the cake were you know
michael's famous cake recipe
and michael makes these cakes all the
time and then
dave says hey michael i boo can i have
one of those yeah i booted mr david out
i'm
doing this whole thing over again and uh
i want one of michael's special cakes
yeah of course there's no question yes
but if the if the
question were as happened to that poor
baker in colorado right if you called me
and you said hey michael
i need you to bake me a cake that is not
i don't
it doesn't it's not just a rainbow flag
cake i want it to be like a
very vivid depiction i want there to be
bed sheets crumpled everywhere
i want i want this to be a specific bed
sheets
i've got all these ideas in my yeah then
i couldn't do that
i couldn't i couldn't uh participate in
the artistic act of depicting this thing
yeah which is contrary to the catholic
definition of marriage yes
but would i sell you the michelin
special cake of course yes so what is
the i don't know what the answer is on
that so that's
you're deep in the weeds i know i would
say my answer is i
i would not uh bake the cake because i
don't like to bake
so this is really more of a so i took
this as more of a baking issue
yes like it's like would i make steak
for gay people
yeah no way absolutely no never yes no
no
you've had my steak it's magnificent
thank you yes it's juicy
it's hot it's delicious yes um
so i would make steak for gate but i'm
not just this is more of a
baking is very technical measurements i
don't yeah you're right
you made more of a broad societal yes
philosophical yeah i just made it about
the baking yes that's a fair point i've
never had your baking
yeah and i don't bake okay
uh me oh yeah
that's me yes two more after this two
more
at a dinner party when someone says
at a dinner party when someone says i
will stay in los angeles do you believe
them
these guys are good these guys are good
i have nothing to add to this other than
you're a bastard you're a
you're a liar you know what here's what
i will say
i'm going to put this to yes because no
one's ever lied to me about that
you know you haven't been burned the way
i've been burned i have not been scorned
and burned all right two more here we go
speechless controlling words controlling
minds
will sell more copies than don't burn
this book thinking for yourself
in the age of one reason oh god i do
uh oh so this is what you think i think
we both
we both know i think relative to the
cultural phenomenon and despite
dead yes putting words in this book
and everything and you know i really
i'll tweet about it i appreciate it you
blurbed it you blurbed it yeah
you know uh even just on the i felt i
had a
decent title yeah no you have a great
title it's a great title
they don't beat don't burn this book it
doesn't
when harry became sally yeah by ryan
anderson yeah yeah don't burn this book
yeah 12 rules for life those are the
greatest book titles
in speechless is pretty great though
thank you it makes the point
i would say on a technical side for my
first book to be
like this is my final definitive why
left the left kind of thing
it has like a really broad appeal yeah
where you're gonna get
your core conservatives and then move
out from that you're right but just it's
like a technical like who buys books
you're right you're right with all due
respect and the fact that you're
disagreeing you're drinking my drink
again
um but for the fact that you're to my
success huh
come on your success okay yeah all right
there's the last one this is it
okay okay
being gay helped my career
just for the record i thought you were
bi yeah okay i don't even realize and
your wife
the way you guys have done this thing
with the kid
being gay has helped my career but you
read that
but i read this so now it could be no
but this would be a statement
like that you would agree with right so
like this could be you saying this
statement too
yeah being gay just just
my being gay has helped my career your
being gay has helped your career but
you're not gay
can we answer the question please so i'm
going to say so i'm answering for you
yes being gay has helped my career in
that you're not
gay i think i have to say
no dave you am i missing you're so
closed-minded yeah you know this is
because typical
close-minded conservative yeah
gay has multiple meanings and you are
gay and i am pretty
you are and you like all those words yes
yes
and i talk with your hands you know and
conservatives they're always so
doer and angry and stuff but i think i'm
pretty gay yeah
you know i'm a gay conservative right
like if if before gay men
homosexuals yeah there would be a bunch
of guys at the bar yes
they're having a gay old time i can't
believe that you would be one of them
you know i think being a little light in
the loafers has helped my career you are
the very definition of gay
you are the gayest to uh to
this very very gay conservatism
we did it knowles well it's amazing what
comes out after a few drinks
i enjoyed being on youtube yeah we had a
good run you get a good run
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
you